au marché de fontenay le fleury on
trouve des fleurs de la viande des
fruits des légumes mais tous les
habitants font le même constat les prix
ont augmenté on commence à moins bon
acheter déjà ses lettres notre cher
regarder les prix aujourd'hui se nourrir
ça revient très faire quand on n'a pas
le temps de faire soi même la cuisine ou
de cuisine et que j'ai fait pendant des
années
et aujourd'hui c'est très compliqué
alors pour éviter de perdre des clients
certains producteurs ont choisi de faire
des promotions en fonction de leur
récolte bat on sent que les gens ont
moins d'argent qui commence dès fois ils
vont acheter vraiment juste ce qu'il
faut ils vont pas en acheter plus oui
ils vont faire les promos comme la les
pommes de terre sont moins chères à 2
kilo les pommes ce don qui vont prendre
des deux qui n'ont comme ça se garde
mais pour d'autres c'est plus compliqué
la demande avait fait un petit papier
explicatifs pour nos clients justement
pour l'expliquer qu'avec même
l'augmentation
l'électricité du gaz et de la tonnes de
blé donc elle est passée elle a cadré
mais je crois depuis le temps oui ce
sera à peu qu'on va doubler surtout
doublé depuis temps et du coup bas comme
nous nos poulets
l'élevage de manière générale et nourris
avec des serial avec du maïs avec tout
ça pas forcément les bâtiments sont
chauffés au gaz à l'électricité
nous on peut pas répercuter tout ça
enfin on est obligé d'augmenter nos crus
en france le prix de l'électricité a été
limitée à 4% en février grâce au
bouclier mis en place par le
gouvernement
une remise de 18 centimes sur les
carburants a aussi été instauré cette
mesure est d'ailleurs prolongé pour
quatre mois supplémentaires concernant
l'alimentation c'est environ une hausse
des prix de 14 % depuis janvier cela
concerne surtout les huiles la farine et
les pâtes le nouveau gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron devrait annoncer en
premier projet de loi sur le pouvoir
d'achat en juin après les législatives